have you ever gotten caught having
something oh no
no do i have to tell the story yes okay
mom don't watch this
[Music]
are you two sexually active with each
other according to my mom no
but uh actually yes yes
we are sexually active with each other
not each other's first
first our lasts our last yeah yes we are
absolutely we were both um sexually
active before we met each other
about a month into like officially
dating i think was when we became
sexually active
no we're in a open relationship but with
each other it's more of an emotional
relationship emotional
are you sexually active with other
people yeah yes we see eye to eye on
everything
yeah and if there is a boundary we want
to set we'll just talk about it when it
comes up
yeah do your parents know you're
sexually active did you tell them
well considering we got sex dice from
his mom i think they know
my mom does she knows that we're like
safe
my parents don't know so i guess if
they're watching
this sorry about that more open to you
i haven't like talked with my mom about
it but she's been sort of like
not dropping hints but like i opened my
desk door and there's just like condoms
in there
and i'm like okay i did not tell them
just saying the word sex is too scary
for them because i grew up catholic i
always had the thought that i would save
my
virginity until marriage i did not have
like
the desire to have sex until i
um was dating yuan i think it's like the
best thing that i
decide to like do this with him did you
feel pressured to have sex no
no no that's a good question i would say
the pressure for me
was to like have sex
by a certain time almost because i
didn't want to get like
too old and realize like oh my gosh you
know i haven't done anything yet
and like it's gonna be so bad or nervous
and stuff
i think if i could go back and tell
myself like dude relax like
everything's gonna be fine like you're
not pressured to do anything i no longer
put pressure on myself to have sex
when we first started out i felt like
like i felt like i would lose uh
his interest yeah i think i was like
putting the pressure on myself and maybe
like rushing a little bit too much but
um it's fine like i learned from my
mistakes and like
i'm i'm moving on and yeah yeah
have you ever gotten caught having sex
oh no no
no i'm glad oh my god
that would no her little brother walked
in it was so awkward like
oh my god and i'm pretty sure he like
saw some stuff he was not supposed to
see at such an age
i kind of was like are you okay
my siblings don't get like sex education
from my parents
so i feel like it's up to me to like
tell them like
you're not alone if you feel these like
feelings do i have to tell the story yes
okay mom don't watch this i'm at school
in college
and i told my roommate the night before
i clearly didn't make it clear enough
and i was like do you
do not come in like please we had
already made arrangements for you to
sleep in a different room you know
he didn't even know he did he just
he swiped the car to win it and he was
like i need socks
[Laughter]
is sex always pleasurable do you feel
like you know what you're doing
i think i know what i'm doing i sure
don't know what i'm doing that's not to
say that i'm like bad at it
it's just if it's something that i've
never done before
i have no clue sure i i haven't had a
non-pleasurable experience
that i know of i've had some funny
experiences
i have no clue what i'm doing i'll be
honest
my first time was with a girl uh she was
my first
it was your first experience with a guy
which yeah it was like really new for me
and i was like
oh i was like okay like i guess this is
how this works but i do feel like it's
enjoyable
especially with someone that you love
and care about it's enjoyable for me
it's kind of like something that
a lot of people put a lot of emphasis on
like it should be like this
perfect like super romanticized like
idea
or whatever but i i mean it's always
going to be special
to me no matter what it's not going to
feel like
a fireworks fairy tale moment constantly
no absolutely not it is definitely a
grow as you go
thing for sure really depends on the fit
and the person
to make sure if it's pleasurable or not
do you know what you're doing yeah i
think so for the most part
yeah it's not that i hope so maybe i'm
doing it completely wrong
and i don't even know i would probably
tell you do you
always practice safe sex yes
always i got tested um yes came back
negative he got tested too
so yeah um i think that's really
important um
especially like with like gay
guys like i don't know like it's
definitely like pretty like
relevant and like um it's something that
should be talked about and also like you
should know your status like really
it's not even just about condoms it's
like you gotta make sure about
everything else
yeah we both don't really want like kids
right now because that's like a lot of
responsibility
[Laughter]
how do you know you and your partner are
ready
i'm actually a diagnosed ptsd from
sexual assault survivor
and i was just kind of coming to terms
with that diagnosis right when i met
david
i kind of had to be open with him about
the whole thing
because i didn't really have a choice i
don't know i feel like that's a very
good strength we have now too
but it was a very interesting way to
start a relationship there's definitely
a need to be like
are we ready and then you can figure it
out that way it's there's nothing wrong
with you know
absolute total verbal confirmation for
me it was just kind of a thing that
happened
but oh my god that makes it sound like
you know it makes it sound like i went
to a bakery and decided
not how you should choose your partners
yeah
things were just kind of escalating so i
was like well you know
uh it seems kind of natural at this
point it's the comfortability and trust
no matter how silly or stupid i look
like it'll be totally fine
we're all in this together and i got
pretty silly
[Laughter]
do you have access to birth control how
did you ask your parents about it
i didn't ask my parents about it i just
go to cvs right quick
buy a condom or to buy a condom or two
because they sell them singularly
i basically went to ask my mom because i
had like a really really heavy period
and she was like um i guess we'll move
on with that when you're like
closer to having sex and i was like
about that
before going to school my mom talked to
me about it and she bought me
a big costco variety pack of condoms
yeah it had like five different types
and it was
huge and i brought it to school with me
how did you ask your partner to have sex
was there a conversation we actually
like had the conversation over face time
because i was really like shy talking
about sexual stuff
i was able to kind of gather my thoughts
and i mean like i could look away when i
wanted to like i could just set my phone
down and be like okay
this is what i want to say like this is
what i want to do so it was much easier
that way
the first encounter was a year
yeah probably one year and then
penetrated was
like two i think the first time we had
like penetrative sex we like planned the
day oh yeah
oh that was done that one was planned it
was like like batman like planning stuff
like like we're gonna go here here here
we're gonna make sure nobody's here here
here it was super important to me
that david knew that just being in a
relationship wasn't like an automatic
you know consent yeah checking in is key
yeah
because i felt like i was definitely
struggling with being able to speak up
um i mean like i feel like usually we
like do like a quick little like
check-in yeah like yes i asked him i
just
like hey do you want to have sex today
or when we're kissing i don't assume
that he wants to have sex like when
we're just making out
we just like ask like do you want to
continue do you want to do this
she's very different like very very
directly oh yeah eating cheetos or
something which will ask you like
did you want to sure
her love language is physical touch and
mine is not
then over time i kind of got used to it
but we definitely had to have like a few
talks
it's not like physicalizing like holding
hands or cuddling it's more like
laying on top of each other yeah just
stupid things like that
what is something that you wish you had
learned in the sex
i wish they talked about not necessarily
the act of doing it but rather the stuff
that leads up to it the stuff that
you need to talk to your partner about i
feel like people's shame
girls especially in high school and
middle school they're slut-shamed and
said like that's wrong or that's like
nasty and it's not at all and it's very
like normal for
um girls and women to have sexual
feelings in middle school i i was i
don't think i was ever taught the
difference between gender and sex
and so oh yeah why it's not part of
health education i have no clue
i feel like better sex education would
allow for like less teen pregnancies and
i wish i learned about like the lgbt
community in there
because like i'm a queer woman and i
almost felt like a part of me was kind
of left out i mean obviously no one not
everyone wants to learn about like
homosexual relationships of course
because like not everyone
most people aren't but i feel like they
should have like an optional thing that
you could
yeah just learn just to know i had to
like resort to a lot of stuff online
that they didn't even like talk about
like it's a whole new world like
aladdin was right like it's a whole new
world they should do something in school
but i just
don't have an answer on how they should
do it because it's really hard to figure
out
but i have to sit through this straight
sex stuff so you know what
i yeah
i'm gonna do
you